a manager of the New York Yankees
pleased to have back here on the show
first time since he was manager used to
have him back in the day talking when he
was with ESPN he's Aaron Boone how are
you Eric I'm doing good how are you
written a long time thanks for you Dave
how are you feeling should I ask how
you're doing I mean because it seems
like everybody else around you is uh
needs to look both ways before crossing
the street yeah we feel like in a lot of
ways we're getting better but getting
getting guys back we got Dede back
obviously and hopefully more guys soon
but I'm feeling well so I mean obviously
sometimes you got to let your smile be
your umbrella I mean the Gardner injury
if you will it was it just took this
whole thing to new heights that even
even even thrown helmets coming back at
you could could lead to an injury I mean
have you ever experienced anything like
this before
Aaron I would say the amount of the
amount of injuries we've dealt with
really starting from spring training you
know to really core guys and obviously
really important people to our team has
been has been oh you know a lot and
probably more than I've I've been a part
of certainly but to these guys credit
man they've they've all and our
organizations credit we feel like we've
built really good depth and and whether
we've had guys from from our
minor-league system come up and
contribute whether guys that we've
brought in from outside the organization
everyone has really stepped up and
played a significant part up and down
the roster and allowing us to to win
games and we certainly look forward to
getting our guys back but the the
expectation hasn't changed and that's we
when we show up to the ballpark we
expect to go out and do whatever it
takes to get a win and and that's been
it been a cool thing to witness that
singular focus that these guys have
really had each and every day well I
mean is there somebody specific and
guess who but I'll just throw it out
there somebody specific whose job it is
to inform you each time that somebody is
going on to the injured list and that
person now shows up at the door
of your office you're like please don't
it means that is that happening well
yeah Steve Steve Donahue and I have
developed an interesting relationship
you know I look at him with squinted
eyes anytime I see him and just wait
whether I'm getting good news or bad
news unfortunately he's had that he's
had to bring a lot of injuries stuff our
way but they've also done a great job
and bringing these guys back and getting
these guys on the mend and and we feel
like we're we're getting closer to
getting more and more healthy well in
terms of that and because i know i when
i speak to managers or coaches certainly
in the NFL they prefer to talk about the
successes with those who have played as
opposed to the injuries and less that
could be taken as an excuse of anything
but let me just quickly if you don't
mind what when do we expect the
following back Aaron judge what can you
tell me about him Aaron so Aaron salmon
Tampa now he'll start getting live ABS
maybe even a a rehab assignment
potentially starting over the next
probably week or so he's doing really
well he's been he's been taking full BP
doing his defensive work running the
injuries out of there you know now it's
just a matter of how much game action
are we gonna get them and and so he
could be you know he's getting close to
being able to start a rehab assignment
so really moving in the right direction
with Aaron what about Stanton Giancarlo
Stanton Stanton is scheduled to start a
rehab assignment tomorrow tomorrow night
with Tampa he'll play two games there
and then probably go up with our
triple-a team over the weekend and then
you know we'll see how much more or at
that time if we want to bring him but
John Carlos knocking on the door as well
what about Severino Aaron SEVIS just in
the playing catch I think he's I think
he's out 290 feet today so still
building up to the long toss that's been
all going well he's been throwing now
for about a week or ten days and and
everything's gone well so far so once he
gets back to the long toss then we'll
start to consider a mound getting them
on the mound and once he does that then
it as a starting pitcher look at it as
training situation where he starting
spring at that point so he's a ways off
but everything that we're seeing with
him has been encouraging and then last
one Betances is he in the similar boat
Severino so Delon actually through two
hitters last week or or a few days ago
and then had some soreness coming out of
that so he's coming back up to New York
he'll see the doctor today all the
preliminary tests look good it doesn't
look like anything's too serious there
but but it's certainly something that we
want to make sure that we're not having
him push through anything unnecessarily
so we'll have a better feel for him here
over these next couple days Aaron Boone
Yankees manager here on the Rich Eisen
show all right so you're a year-plus
into this what what has been the most
unexpected part of your job coming out
of the booth and after years of playing
and being around it through your family
that you just didn't expect in a way to
be a manager in Major League Baseball
you know I guess the the volume of
things that that come across the desk
you know everything from from things
that happen between the lines to you
know things that happen that have
nothing to do with the game because you
know we're dealing with you know on a
daily basis between players staff
traveling party you know you know we're
40 50 60 people that you know you do
become like a family so you there's a
lot of things that happen not only in
baseball but people's lives that that
come across the desk that are all things
that you have to manage and deal with
over the course of a long season so I
think the volume of that and how you
handle that is probably been the biggest
thing I've loved it
and I you know in a way in my mind going
into this prepared myself for that but
until you really go through it it's hard
to really fathom why don't you wear the
pinstripes every now and again I get a
lot of questions about that I like my I
like my my sweatshirts and you know but
I'll bust it out every now and then
especially now as it starts to warm up
you
you'll see it every now okay actually my
eight-year-old asked me that the other
day Aaron I mean I get a boss and kids
are noticing my you know people are just
noticing it's just I don't know it's
just that was a big topic last year and
I ended up wearing it more than I think
people realize okay okay very good so
taking on the Mets you know I mean it 97
was the first year that the Mets and
Yankees played each other in the regular
season we're now it's unbelievable we're
now in our third decade of Yankees and
Mets playing each other in regular
season wood is there anything special
about it still I think there is because
you know you get a sense that look in
the course of 162 games anytime you have
something in in the course of season we
go to London and a couple weeks to play
Boston and that's going to be that's
going to be a great experience but
anytime you have these big series these
series that you know draw draw a little
more attention you know obviously in in
New York here where people on both sides
of the aisle you know that it means a
little bit more I think you can sense
that you can feel that so I think in the
course of a long season anytime you have
something that's you know at least a
little bit unique that kind of gets the
juices going a little bit I think it's a
great thing and a fun thing to be a part
of especially in this great city that we
get to call home Aaron Boone here in the
Rich Eisen show a few more minutes left
with the Yankees manager I'm sure you
heard the news about David Ortiz last
night and it looks like he's out of the
figurative woods here it was just
horrible what what happened to him you
got a good poppy story but doing battle
with him obviously you you got the
better of the Red Sox you know three
vice versa no Ford you got a good Big
Papi story for me no just just my you
know experiences with them over the
years is everything that we hear about
them I mean there's a there's a
graciousness to them the the competitor
that lies within him the good nature
that he is he's just he's just a really
charismatic great great guy and and
certainly praying for a speedy recovery
for him and hoping that it is something
that that he avoided something very
but uh we're all thinking about a Big
Papi today that's for sure yeah I know
we really was just kind of shocking how
often do you get the 2003 home run you
hit brought up to you is it not often
how often does that happen
Aaron quite a bit remarkably I mean it's
you know as time has gone on I've kind
of appreciated it a little bit more and
and just just when I say that just what
it means to so many people whatever
again whatever side of the aisle or
wherever whoever gets here for the
amount of intimate stories that I've
heard in regards to you know and as a
sports fan I can relate like I remember
exactly what I was doing at that moment
and in the left level of stories that
I've received over the years has been
remarkable and made me really appreciate
having a little piece and such a great
rivalry you got a good one one that may
be awkward or that made you feel awkward
so Ryan Flaherty infielder big league
infielder was uh was going to school up
and up in New England and they were at a
party I don't know if he's in college or
high school but they're at a party and
they were on the second floor or
whatever and they hit the homerun it was
a kind of a Red Sox Sandom party and
they said they took the TV and threw it
out the window on the street so the shot
heard round the world knocked the
television in a way out of a out of a
house that's right that's right isn't
that amazing and your brother was
calling the game was in the booth for
Fox so that was great on and you came in
as a pinch runner as well if I'm not
mistaken yeah you know you weren't even
prepared for well I mean how do you even
prepare for a moment like that Aaron I
don't know you just do just get up there
and you sweet hey Aaron have a great
time tonight against the Mets you know
I'm being a native New Yorker I watch
every night on yes with my my kids so
I'm really enjoying the exploits of why
the team that you're putting out there
on the field with a whole bunch of
players making the most of their
opportunities right now I appreciate
that it's always good talking hopefully
we'll do it again soon that's Aaron
Boone Yankees manager here in the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app